- that men on Batman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith
I am mark Rinaldi we are at the American
a comedy company here in San Diego put
your hands together to the folks at home
know you exist and we are all here in
town for a comic-con international
comic-con 2018
this year's comic-con the sub theme of
which is comic-con 2018 :
[ __ ] Batman because I don't know if
anyone saw that very hostile Titans
trailer but apparently Robins got big
issues with Batman that's where we are
at this point I put up a tweet where I
was like when I was a kid
Robin used to say [ __ ] like holy
eggshells Batman now Robin says [ __ ]
like [ __ ] Batman [ __ ] you in your
Batmobile [ __ ] I was feeling very
very good all day long here at con man
this is Lucy first time I went to
comic-con 1995 we came with mall rats
that showed it at Horton Plaza so I've
been coming for like 23 years off and on
and most of those very much on thank you
however thanks to recent health events I
don't know if you know this mark but I
did have a heart attack fairly please do
tell a story for another time every
other time but after that like you know
I became vegan and [ __ ] it used to be
happy now I'm [ __ ] vegan and so in
that time I've dropped some weight since
the heart attack so this is I don't want
to say this to brag but it is noteworthy
and I want to put it on the record
because next year it'll probably be way
different and [ __ ] this is the absolute
thinnest I've ever been at a comic-con
in my life
I I weigh less at this comic um that I
did my first comic-con in 1995 man I'm
sitting into my 95 comic-con jorts
so like acid-wash like a [ __ ] pain
totally and I never thought I'd wear him
again they were in a frame hanging over
my bed so I got to break the frame and
pull them back on and [ __ ] yeah that's
been nice
I've been up working on there for the
IMDB folks again this year's my third
year atop the IMD boat where we
interview folks the movers and shakers
of comic-con and I met many people
famous people today some of whom were
like you're like a legend around here
and I was like [ __ ] thanks man I was
feeling real good about myself so much
so they like during lunch not only was
double-time it today I was interviewing
people for IMDB my lunch time I went and
did interviews for myself for the
Halloween TV show that we got going
right now at rivet tv.com so I went out
to do press for that and I went over to
variety they have a boat they copied the
IMDB and they started doing a boat I was
welcome boat
everybody wants a boat now so I went
over there sat down did an interview
with them felt very good about myself
felt like you know what man in this
industry of show this business of show
I've been doing it nearly 25 years at
this point like I'm like people like me
people respect me man people people know
who I am and then I read this
variety the very people I sat down to
interview with like the James was lovely
aboard the variety boat yes [ __ ]
exactly that yeah yes thanks for killing
my joke but [ __ ] yes that's exactly
what it was let me find the [ __ ]
tweet I wasn't fast enough variety
writes Kevin James is thrilled about the
two upcoming Joker movies and there's
the picture of me man like I was just on
their [ __ ] boat talking to him and
it's me in the interview Clippard [ __ ]
and I was it was crazy I said I saw that
I'm like [ __ ] man I'm a nobody I'm not a
I'm not nobody I'm Kevin [ __ ] James
is what I am I just wish I had some of
that Kevin James [ __ ] money man
almost willful ignorance because you're
wearing a [ __ ] hockey jersey with
your name on the back
yes like we don't want to know no doubt
I'm gonna get a hockey a crest for my
new jersey that's just Kevin James's
face people are really [ __ ] broken
when they see it they're like buh
James ception James unchanged ception
keV inception
second draft nice job how has your con
been so far has anyone mistaken you for
somebody I get occasionally like
Reginald veljohnson that's right sure
does uncle was an ass right now I'm off
to buy Twinkies goodbye
yeah and occasionally I get like are you
like uncle Phil's younger brother
Wow I'll take that one I don't watch
that show lot but now that I think about
it yeah I get it it's been a weird
[ __ ] convention for me tell me why
before you say anything I've been seeing
castle rock everywhere mark worked on
Castle Rock yeah and I'll do even one
better it's one thing to be like I see
it everywhere because naturally this is
a great place for them to talk about it
to pay for activations and kind of
publicize it but I'm talking about as a
professional now on the IMD boat where I
am a captain of sorts and [ __ ] we were
trying to get Castle Rock to come up be
interviewed and stuff and they were so
in demand they were like we would love
to but we just absolutely have no time
so that's it's a heavily buzzed about an
in-demand show IMDB wanted on the boat
as they're like it's really high on the
star meter and [ __ ] like that a lot of
it there's a lot of clicks on it so
there's a lot of interest in that show
before anyone sees anything have they
shown anything yet they're showing the
pilot tomorrow tomorrow at 12:45 at the
Castle Rock panel which I am moderating
which also is [ __ ] weird because I
worked on the show I know all the
answers I'm gonna ask the questions
about yeah tell me about that time that
I was really smart in the room remember
that I'm vented like half this [ __ ] you
give credit but that's cool tell me
about how great I am
you're heading into the room with the
teachers edition in your hand well
that's why it's so surreal for me like
I'm incoming I'm not 25 years deep I'm
still young and I'm 18 years coming to
this thing and I've never come before
for a show that I worked on and that's
the only reason I'm here
but and then for that show to be [ __ ]
everywhere like it's bizarre it's so
surreal what is their activation they
call it now it's called an activation
what's their booth what's their exhibit
there's a haunted house I think like a
cross from the Marriott Marquis okay and
they sunk half a car in this a mother
fountain is that the half a car the
fountain is theirs I saw that now I
asked my wife I was like do you think
that's the comment or is that like did
that just happen should we call somebody
yeah that's for them that's for them
yeah what does that is that can you tell
I mean I know you can't tell us anything
but I mean at this point I could tell
you everything because the show's
[ __ ] almost out I can do whatever I'm
a free man that's true I'm holed into
India's now you're gonna get a call like
you're no longer the moderator yeah
also never come back you're dead to JJ
what is the car in the waters that have
something to do with the plot yeah it's
it's part of the teaser of the show I
think where a certain person who may or
may not work at Shawshank penitentiary
may or may not sink his car in Castle
Lake which sort of kicks off all of the
events of the pilot of the show right so
you got me you've already intrigued me
with that that sounds yeah they should
let you do the commercial where you're
like you may or may not watch the show
these things may or may not happen there
may or may not be a Cujo on the loose
I'm not gonna say there is or isn't
I mean [ __ ] all these people were friend
and never once were you like cujo's on
the show by who Joey's the [ __ ] out of
Annie Wilkes sexually Wow none of that
happens does it I mean I may or may not
be able to say that it totally does or
does not happen all right I'm tuning in
why's it been a weird confi though it's
just I've never quite seen because I
mean if you're in a TV show if you're
working on a TV show there's 10 people
in a room and those 10 people are making
up a [ __ ] show like it is also the
best job in the world and also really
[ __ ] hard and you won't believe it
and I know and that's fine because we're
just having a conversation for like
eight months but it's just the ten of us
in a room and then suddenly the product
the fruits of the ten of us in that room
are plastered around an entire district
of a city and that is weird shift
somebody said it's like because the like
say something I'm gonna look stupid so
like a car goes in the lake and then
[ __ ] a year later there's a car in
the fountain and shares a car in the
[ __ ] fountain and I've covered this
show like as a journalist for 17 of
those eighteen years so I would be
trying to get into that panel I would
trying to get a good seat so I can cover
it I could be like jockeying for
interviews with people and that was my
life for a long time and so to be on the
other side of that of something so
[ __ ] huge and weird I can't quite
square the circle in my brain I can't
quite grok that this is now what my
comic-con life is like I'm on the boat I
interviewed Shane Black and some of the
cast of the predator including miss
Olivia Munn who for those of us with a
longer memory started over at g4 doing
this that very thing interviewing people
and stuff like that now she's on the
other side of it so I've mentioned to
her well I was like [ __ ] man when we met
you were interviewing me and now I'm
interviewing you and stuff like that we
switched careers or whatever [ __ ]
you're like the Olivia Munn of writers
man
I mean I got the curves for it I've been
building this body for 46 years and it's
finally come to fruition you got its I
locked my friend help thank you thank
you thank you
yeah that's got to be fun man's gotta be
exciting to be here in a different
capacity than you've ever been here it
is super cool I I can come on the boat
I'll take you
yeah no we'll talk about Castlerock yeah
yeah oh my god I mean this is so dirty
you're like I could come on the boat and
I'm like I'll take you
we are seamen the but yeah I believe me
I'll tell them I was like look I get an
interview a writer from Casa we got one
guy yeah they're like a writer really
that's true man good that's the currency
down plus I could tell him I'm like this
is my co-host on fat man I'm Batman
double dip yeah absolutely yeah it's not
like I'll be like what am I gonna talk
to him about who are you tell me your
story yeah I'll be the first thing I'll
ask is Cujo really in that [ __ ] show
cuz that would be amazing
like yes the okay we should probably
dive in because it being comic-con
there's probably a [ __ ] abundance of
news that we can get to there is some
[ __ ] that happened over the last couple
of days yeah like literally and
including up to like before we went just
on the show like shit's been breaking
it's Comic Con so there's news happening
all the time this is the section of the
show where mr. mark barnard n'
aggregates a bunch of news and then we
talk about it don't applaud it too hard
he just wanted the Internet and [ __ ]
pulled it off it's the hard work is
getting to print this [ __ ] somewhere in
San Diego and I can like find me
Business Center but to be fair also like
you were a member of the was a fifth day
Fourth Estate fourth this fourth estate
you are a journalist at one point I will
and you put in many years as a
journalist totally so that leaves you
free to steal other journalists [ __ ] so
we could do it on our show I am not
stealing I'm really a ting smart see I'm
coach it a ting and regurgitating
somebody else's work spit that baby bird
[ __ ] my man so did you know yes speaking
of [ __ ] Batman okay there's a character
who will never [ __ ] Batman who may be
getting a TV show
Batwoman Oh see what I did there I saw
like a really good riddle like I would
have said 10 people before and then when
you said bad we'll never [ __ ] bad man
well it's one of those like who's buried
in Grant's Tomb and I'm like what the
[ __ ] what kind of head scratcher is this
but you're right yeah him and bad woman
wouldn't because she doesn't like dudes
no not even any other reasons yes bat
woman is going to be a CW show yeah
they're they're introducing her in the
cross oh my god are you just learning
that now like where I feel like we've
broken something that somebody else
broke that's what I'd like to be an Uzi
you got a chain saw that musical yeah so
they're introducing bat woman for
whatever the big crossover is for the
big crossover in the Berlanti verse
between arrow and flash and Supergirl
and Legends is going to introduce the
character of bat woman right and so
they're already beginning to develop the
show the located if we're gonna do the
[ __ ] work of introducing her let's
give her a goddamn show because it's
like oh my god we got a character with
bat in the name like they'll never get
Batman because he's viable cinematic
franchise and Batgirl it looks like
they're taken to the big screen as well
as we as we know so this is like the
Berlanti versus best close shot to
getting into the bat mythos and we've
seen what they've done like with
Supergirl
you know they didn't have the rights to
Superman but they had the Supergirl
universe which gives them the rights to
most of the Superman universe so a lot
of great Superman stories were
reappropriation girl stories and stuff
so it feels like they could be able to
do the same thing here like you know
naturally they won't can't be taking the
Joker and stuff like that but they'll
build a rogues gallery for that
character and they could tell a lot of
stories that you've loved in comics
through the Batwoman character you've
loved as Batman as the second bite at
the Apple it's smart man yeah like not
only do you get that woman but you
probably also get Commission of Gordon
which you can now insert into the
arrowverse into the DC verse and that's
worth it that's it gets you so much bat
real estate and probably touches on
characters like like perfer furry
characters that will make you go like oh
[ __ ] there's pretty soon he'll show up
and they'll probably be lots of look you
can't do bat woman without being like
why'd she picked that [ __ ] name so
like they got a reference Batman he may
not be in the show or maybe he is in the
[ __ ] show like how Supergirl had
Superman like the possibilities now are
[ __ ] endless and if I'm Warner
Brothers I'm looking at everything Greg
Berlanti is done with that universe and
all those shows and me like give him the
[ __ ] crown jewels like goddammit give
him [ __ ] Batman he can't [ __ ] do
worse you know than what we've seen so
hopefully this is as a step toward
getting the big two but also like an
anyone in that world will tell you
they're happy to not play with the big
toys and you're forced to be more
creative with more inventive toys that
people haven't picked up before they
took the atom and turned him into a
viable character with Brandon you know
so like it's maybe there's something to
be said for not being allowed to touch
the big two or the big three now which
would include Wonder Woman it forces
them to be more creative with other
great care totally and you know Berlanti
has always been a champion of LGBTQ some
other letter after that awareness and
isn't there one more I a right which I
don't know what that means
but I'm also super old so give me a
second they threw IATSE into that it's a
union it's a union but so for him I
think it's it's a very Wow I was like a
joke Renee yeah
there some teams are back there was like
[ __ ] I you're right not fat man
anymore but so for him he is all about
sort of reintroducing that sense of
equality and inclusion and diversity
into the superior universe so for this
to be the sort of first slash second
because I think isn't there an openly
gay character and legend the Ray the Ray
was introduced during the last crossover
right so but to lead a show like that's
a big [ __ ] deal
big deal so well well done if it ever
happens cuz it's still in development
and it may never happen but good job for
the thing you almost maybe got done
it'll happen I haven't heard of anything
that he's worked on with any of the DC
Universe characters that never went
forward right I mean [ __ ] he was the guy
was like hey let's do Archie you know
and I'm sure people were like Archie go
[ __ ] yourself for a minute until
somebody was like no this could be good
if they all [ __ ] each other it's amazing
yeah he could make anything work man
[ __ ] if your life is broken give it
to Greg Berlanti he'll make a good
version of it
remember when Netflix bought like Mark
Millar and everything he's ever done and
everything he's ever owned the Miller
world yeah our world
they've officially greenlit two TV
series and three movies based on the
Miller world holy [ __ ] yeah and that's a
lot of work it works a lot of [ __ ]
work what are we not deep
let's see they're doing Jupiter's legacy
okay which Stephen tonight who did
daredevil and Spartacus and Buffy the
Vampire Slayer is sure running that nice
they're doing American Jesus which you
know probably not timely at all no good
reason why you would do that show today
but it's about a multilingual series
about American Jesus who's a 12 year old
boy who suddenly discovers he's returned
as Jesus Christ all right so you know
that's not controversial oh it's just a
family romp and then the movies are
Empress which is this big [ __ ] giant
science fiction thing that he did Huck
which is about a Latina seaside town
Huck uses special gifts to do a good
deed each day and then somebody gets
murdered I guess and then Sharky the
bounty hunter which is not Sharky's
machine which I was a little depressed
wasn't Sharky's machine but that's fine
which is in a another sci-fi universe
about a bounty hunter who may or may not
be a shark I really hope he's a [ __ ]
shark he's like we don't wanna be a
[ __ ] shark is it may or man that's a
part of the plot he may or may not be
true that is just my hopes and dreams oh
[ __ ] that stop making a better version
of that show if there's a shark hunting
bounties that is that's great for Mark
Miller holy [ __ ] man he's good dude
and boy that's a lot to green-light at
once he's gonna be busy you really got
to oversee it all of it yeah but I mean
Netflix is in the business of just
dropping [ __ ] by the tongue yeah
everyone tells me that yet every time I
go to pitch something on Netflix they're
like we're good you know like we buy
from everybody but you get the [ __ ] out
I'm tired of this one-way relationship
Netflix I give them my money I want some
of their [ __ ] money man be nice it's
like a savings bond lesson I gave you 20
bucks I went $1,000 in the back end yeah
$1,000 in the back end the mark
Bernardin's story coming soon to
lifetime it's the name of my sex tape
what else is newsworthy you know how we
love the doom god damn it well I mean
let's but let's be be honest yes there
are many dudes to love including the
great original by Frank Herbert yes we
don't well I can't speak for you but I
don't love that I do love that oh do you
all right now you stand alone I only go
so far as doing as David Lynch is doing
which i think is a fantastic [ __ ]
movie but oh my god that's fantastic
all I see is the tradies I want to kill
that and I respect the books that they
came from I know those books influenced
George Lucas as well yeah but I can't
say that I've ever read them that's you
did you actually read the book I've read
the first three which are [ __ ]
awesome and super dense and I will never
read them again because I got other [ __ ]
to do but yeah it's it's about like what
it would really be like as a superhero
like what happens when you insert a
superhero into a political situation
where nobody else can do the [ __ ] that a
superior can do
and how does that affect the world and
slash universe at large by some dude who
can control [ __ ] with mind right so it's
pretty great I too love the David Lynch
thing I saw the miniseries that sci-fi
did did you like that Jason Mewes loved
it that's his dude whenever I talk about
dune he starts talking about a different
dune and I'm like that ain't [ __ ]
dune he's like I watch 12 [ __ ] hours
it is dude like but yeah that's his
doing but it wasn't I like it but it one
of the first movies that I was ever
challenged by was doing because it makes
no [ __ ] sense at the David Lynch whoo
yeah yeah yeah it's like I spent like my
dad I remember he was so proud of
himself he bought like one of those
first VCRs I think at the time and I
brought home doing it was like here you
go
I bought you a science fiction picture
like you like I don't know why I did
that accent because he's from Haiti and
he's not at all like this is what you
like it's like way more Frenchy it was
kind of racist from that fountain was
like he brought it home and I watched it
and didn't understand any of it and then
watch it again immediately like it was
the first time that I engaged with the
thing I didn't even though your Virginia
Madsen is cute and Shaunie why not I get
it and I like to run Blade Runner and
all of these things were cool
you were like [ __ ] and the movie was
like the Benny Jesuit witch's box and
[ __ ] in your hand and I shall not fear I
feel mount killer whatever fear I feel
will pass over me and through me and
when it is gone I shall remain remove
your hand young Cuban that's a line from
the movie we just did a thing yeah if
you know dude that was kind of hot why
my will alone I set my mind in motion
yes don't do it hard I want see yes that
was my doing so I own I have a very soft
spot for many people I have many
different dunes and stuff but there's
been no definitive dune yet to be honest
I didn't even knew we liked him this guy
who did the arrival he did and Sicario
and other [ __ ] before that some of which
was in French and this year he did the
Blade Runner movie he did believe under
2049 yeah he is making a doing movie yes
oh that's right he talked about this
washed-up doing James Bond to do dune
number one respect for that right like
that's a great [ __ ] move like James
Bond is very tempting but be like look I
can't do anything different for Bond and
stuff but I could like he he's talked
about the David Lynch dune and he's just
like oh sweet man you rock thanks he's
talked about the David Lynch dune and
his thing is like I love that movie but
if you know those books like there's a
lot that that wasn't covered and one day
I would like to do it it sounds like
he's getting his chance he's doing it
and he just cast his lead oh [ __ ]
really Timothy Shalom a did you feel the
room that is a good [ __ ] reference
yeah Wow so wait he would play Paul he
put Paul trainees this that means this
movie gets greenlit number one everyone
loves this [ __ ] kid right now and
number two you got a director that
everybody digs and [ __ ] and even though
the Blade Runner movie didn't light the
world on fire got a lot of respect
people really liked it and wasn't it up
for awards did he get wins
Deacon's wand so it won Academy Awards
and stuff this is guy who's on a streak
he was nominated for a rival as well
that there's no way this movie doesn't
get made now he put that kid in there
block and he's all like dewy and
handsome and elfin and young and slight
so you can make a lot of movies with him
if you want if you're gonna cover a
bunch of those boldly and it could be as
gay as you want it to be I believe
that's the subtitle soon as a as you
want it to be
have you seen our sand dicks that is all
we do here men with giant sand dicks
between their legs this sleeper has
awakened if you walk with our rhythm you
won't disturb the world [ __ ] Frank
Herbert's spinning in his grave right
now going it wasn't meant to be dirty
it's a Christ parable that's him
spinning very nice I want to see this
movie in a big bad way man [ __ ] yeah
there's no release date there's not
there's no like production gate but it's
all waiting and well let's think about
it it's his back door superhero
franchise you've pegged it perfectly
backdoor we all want a little back to
her superhero franchise don't we dad
that's like instead of doing of course
Marvel or DC he's found a way to do his
own superhero movie and legendary bought
the film and TV rights
legendaries making it so they can
absolutely spend this into a TV show if
they want they can do the thing they've
been talking about in Hollywood of we're
gonna do a movie and then between movies
we're gonna do a season of TV and then
come back and do a sequel there was
supposed to that with Dark Tower and
then the Dark Tower sucked and so they
didn't do that good was that the
official reason I think so like we could
do this but it's sucked I mean it should
work like it feels like it goes the
other way next files do it in Reverse
they had a successful run on TV then did
a theatrical movie and then went back
and continued the show for a while if I
remember correctly two movies one of
which nobody gave a [ __ ] about the one
with the werewolves or something puts it
where Bulls oh now see I didn't give a
good well I look forward to this dune
picture man there's Deneb in you is a
wonderful director so I look forward to
that they are making a why the last man
show you knew this yes I think I'd heard
this at one point and this is a beloved
comic book problems [ __ ] people love
the [ __ ] out of Y the last man they
would talk about this needs to be as
something ever since like issue 3 I
believe yeah I mean it's the reason why
Brian Vaughn
got he got the other job riding on lost
when lost was huge because most of the
people read while Damon Lindelof was a
huge fan of why it was like that dude
should be on a TV show Wow yeah like it
had been in features for a while it
flirt with it for movies but they're
legit and making a [ __ ] show so much
they've cast the show they got a cast
member please say it's Timothy sha'lame
so we could watch these [ __ ] fight it
is Barry Keegan oh yogin [ __ ] love
this kid he was in a movie called the
killing of the sacred deer he was Jesus
if you had not seen this [ __ ] movie
it is so worth your time I forget who
put it out maybe it feels like an eight
twenty-four movie this but I think but
holy [ __ ] I never seen a movie like this
and he was phenomenal in a very tricky
role where the whole movie rested on his
shoulders yeah he was also in Dunkirk
yes he was he the boy that spoilers if
you haven't seen it cover your ears he's
a white British guy he's the one that he
dies on the boat right he does down the
boat man he's great actor I'm telling
you that killing a sacred deer movie is
a [ __ ] brain burner man there's a
scene in that movie where you're like
did they just [ __ ] say that Colin
Farrell just admit to that like it's
crazy it's Colin Farrell yeah Colin yeah
you told me about on the podcast I was
like dizzy gonna talk about jerking off
in front of his dad in this movie cuz
this is [ __ ] weird I have to watch it
yes yes you were like what the [ __ ]
there was a time when I walked into my
dad's room when he was sitting there and
I jerked off in front of him that was I
forgot I scrubbed it from my brain yes I
was nothing yeah I watched it like two
weeks ago cuz the new TV show that I'm
on the show called Treadstone which is
in like the whole Jason Bourne universe
is weird [ __ ] whatever but we were
talking a lot about Roman Polanski okay
and and the way he ate awful human being
clearly not a good dude should never be
allowed back in the country she'd
probably still be persecuted but also
made like a handful of great movies
before he turned into an [ __ ] but the
way he would film paranoia like all of
his movies are ultimately about paranoia
and voyeurism and all that
[ __ ] and so when we're talking about you
know sort of espionage and identity and
all the stuff that plays into into
Treadstone don't tell anybody I told you
they are totally gonna fire me anybody
hears that I told you about paranoia and
all that [ __ ]
so never mind but I had to watch I
watched killing of the sacred deal and
it's [ __ ] up yeah it is super [ __ ]
up so thanks it's worth your time yeah
should I watch it because you tell me I
should watch it have you seen black
mayor no let me tell you about the first
episode of Black Mirror the Prime
Minister has to [ __ ] a live pig spoilers
sorry he [ __ ] a pig alright so so yeah
why the last man yes that's where we
work whose cast Barry Keegan is York yes
Diane Lane is the President of the
United States oh [ __ ] Wow who's doing
this show they got some money apparently
yeah FX is doing the show it's an FX
show yes being show run by Michael Green
our boy our boy Michael green Logan and
Blade Runner and there was another
franchise movie was an alien and was
running the first season of American
Gods yeah all in a year which is nuts
but yes the dialing is the president
Barry Keegan is you know Urich Amber
Tamblyn is the daughter of the president
okay
of the United States emo gene boots is
playing hero Brown Yorick sister oh [ __ ]
and a woman named leshawna Lynch is
playing agent 355 well and she's in
Captain Marvel she's also in Captain
Marvel yeah there's probably no better
time than now for y the last man is a
female heavy cast hell yeah like you
know a on the heels of Handmaid's Tale
yes which is is awesome and awful and
dispiriting and will make you want to
cry and curl up in your room and just
wish the world wasn't this way but it
totally is because look where we are
boy they should put that on a poster you
know
you sold the [ __ ] out of that show
missing my calling can't wait to go home
and [ __ ] go to sleep watching that
warm blanket but Mark said he said was
gonna break my soul he was right he did
now I gotta go watch killing of a sacred
deer again but no it is the perfect time
for that show no no duh it really is an
FX it seems as if they're stepping up
the [ __ ] bat is Brian Vaughn working
on it
he will be an executive producer he will
have some involvement in it but he's not
running the show
don't think as I understand it the
writing staff is entirely female ah
except for Michael Green except for
Michael Grimm yes that makes sense
he's like you know what I should be the
only dude in the room because I wanted a
job on that show and I said hey Michael
you know what I've read all of Y the
last man can I be on the show he said no
I like you but know why cuz you're a man
you know why the last man is me not you
that's smart they should do that with
the directors as well might as well it
would not surprise me if they did go off
female directors yeah we're not surprise
me if they did because Ava Duvernay has
done that on Queen sugar like it it's
not precedent to do that then they do it
on jessica jones as well as jessica
jones like you can like nobody would
know it's not like suddenly it's a bad
show because nothing but ladies and it's
amazing and so [ __ ] keep doing it
well if it makes sense do it and it
always makes sense that's that it's
smart particularly with that show hell
yeah well we look forward to that [ __ ]
man another successful DC TV thing it
sounds like vertigo I guess that's
technically they're vertically vertigo
and as I understand it that was the last
great deal vertigo ever made because
very good used to be creator-owned yeah
much like image much like Dark Horse
used to be back in the day and and so
why the last man did so insanely [ __ ]
well all over the world like Brian
Vaughn would say I bought my house based
on the Italian reprints of why the last
man and the deal was so good the
Vertigo's that we can never make another
deal like this because we're losing too
much money and so it's Vaughn's fault
that if you go to vertigo now look now
we're gonna take most of the rights and
you get a piece and it will be healthy
but you will never make Brian Vaughn
money could you imagine if somebody just
slapped you in the face with the [ __ ]
big dick of reality by saying you are
never gonna make Brian cave on money
that would [ __ ] hurt man and you're
like who's Brian like Diana Ross money I
get I'm never gonna make that but Brian
came the first question you should ask
is why and then they're like the last
band anybody all right so what happens
next man let's see were you a fan of
Robocop of course naturally you mean
Paul Verhoeven's I mean Airy Robocop
well farallon's visionary Robocop which
is one of the best movies ever made
absolutely they've made sequels to that
movie which have almost uniformly sucked
they've but not as been as as strong as
the Robocop initial entry that is
putting it right Miller worked on one
really kindly I'm sure I feel Christ
know what I believe was on the second
one or he did yeah he won which is why
he hated Hollywood so much he wouldn't
sell the rights to anything else ever
yeah until Robert Rodriguez showed up
and was like no you can be co-director
of Sin City swear to god it's true story
he hated his experience in Hollywood but
so yes Robocop is getting a another
sequel now a sequel to Paul Verhoeven's
visionary original because that would be
exciting I think that is exactly what
they're gonna do Kevin
well I've read this story and I think
you're wrong mark do tell Kevin they're
making a sequel to the Joel Kinnaman one
that they made a couple years ago and
it's the guy who did that robot movie
what was it called chappie chappie yeah
I'm sure he hates that that's how you
remember a fellow graduate well not even
if yeah I guess I am now he went to the
Vancouver Film School ooh like at which
I went to the Vancouver Film School and
when when we made clerks we were the
most famous [ __ ] like people that
came out of Vancouver film school for
years and [ __ ] and then years later he
made district done so now they're like
we [ __ ] educated the mother
I'm a district 9 you Fox and the guy
that made clerks once me like [ __ ] a
very low key in the background I did a
thing to you guys he's very he's a
wonderful director so wait he the Avant
now I'm telling you the story he is
making a sequel to the revamped Robocop
there's your mistake yeah I mean look
well he's good director so maybe he'll
turn into something and and what a great
thing it would be if he made it more
exciting and people like Ollie's yet
like they're it's not unheard of that
the second movie is better than the
first Star Trek the motion picture I
would argue is not nearly as good as
Star Trek to the Wrath of Khan so this
could go in that direction but let's be
honest if we all had our wish come true
it would be that he directly sequel
eise's the movie we all know with Peter
Weller in it but maybe that's just not
possible at this point although since we
all love Marvel movies we know they
could take Michelle Pfeiffer make her
look [ __ ] 20 so if somebody cared
enough and wanted to spend enough money
Peter Weller well he'd have to agree to
be in it and [ __ ] but they could make a
motor book up again then again all you
got to do is put the [ __ ] bottom half
of that dudes join it's mostly masks
you're right man like that's nothing
he's in the costume for the whole
[ __ ] movie unless it's taking him out
of the costume but they're never gonna
do that because he wants that
all right I want Robocop that's true and
he also looked creepy whenever he took
his helmet off you're like yeah you're
the future of law enforcement I
understand but I believe they put that
as one of his instructional orders and
should never take that helmet off leave
it on it's creepy
leave your hat off yeah that's coming
man you can't stop that movie but that
guy is a really strong director and so I
think we might get a pretty good Robocop
movie to be fair I own that remake
Robocop movie on home video digitally or
whatever and it's it's not bad it's good
it's just not Paul Verhoeven's it's it
lacks a sense of humor the wonderful
thing about the Paul Verhoeven original
was darkly [ __ ] it's Turek and and had
laughs in it not the least of which is I
buy that for a dollar you know
the other one it was like they they were
like what do people like about these
movies they're like the jokes [ __ ] no
when they took them all out and should
just put the action in and when you take
the humor out of Robocop it's a [ __ ]
sad story about a cop who gets killed
and his family thinks he's dead and [ __ ]
he can't really go back to him and stuff
it's really heartbreaking but so the
laughs kind of held its Frankenstein but
with jokes oh my god you're right
you got a review that movie man take a
[ __ ] ten more review it's
Frankenstein with jokes slash mark
barnard go see it is that the end of the
news that is the end of the news my
friend that's the end of the news of
marks collected but let's figure out
what we've heard today big news that
come out at Comic Con and I know this
from working with the good folks at the
IMDB this morning we did a piece at the
end of the day the wrap-up they did a
anniversary panel 10th anniversary panel
for the Clone Wars animated series
that's right that was nice but what they
showed was at the end they dropped a
[ __ ] trailer for a continuing series
they're gonna go finish Clone Wars the
animated [ __ ] series bang we believe
that those don't follow certain thing
closely they did the Clone Wars animated
series stopped and then started rebels
and there was never a real absolute
conclusion you never saw the end of the
Clone Wars and stuff they're actually
going back and do if you watch the
trailer online right now you'll see your
favorites you'll see he'll be one can
open you'll see Anakin Skywalker and
you'll see spoilers wait for it five
four three two one ahsoka ahsoka is in
it as well and when I talked about with
the the kids on the IMDB boat today was
do you think that is a backdoor way to
get that character into the live-action
films like you know that's that's one of
the strongest female characters in the
Star Wars universe but just comes from
the animated realm they never brought
her into the live-action films feels
like this is an opportunity now because
otherwise you got two older characters
Anakin Skywalker we know what happens to
him emo [ __ ]
no obi-wan Kenobi we know what happens
to him as well so ahsoka is a character
from that series and from that world
that has never been in live-action stuff
who you can absolutely go deep on and
that sounds dirtier than I meant ago you
could go you can make whole movies
devoted to that character and you know
there is a kind of scarcity of female
characters in the Star Wars universe is
a big sausage party and then they do
have Princess Leia of course this is the
original strong female character but not
really any more exactly and in a world
where you can't do those stories anymore
you have a character tried true and
tested who Star Wars fans already adore
you pull that character into live-action
you're gonna make so much [ __ ] money
and step so we were on the boat so to
get going who plays her in a live-action
movie right away I said rosario Dawson
who write Fantastic Four was so weird as
while we were on the boat saying it
somebody asked the question somebody
down below on the docks yelled out just
as I was saying it they were like oh
sorry Oh Dawson was a gas badge and it
was [ __ ] rosario Dawson
you son-of-a-bitch who who would you
you're totally welcome to Burroughs area
but who would be the backup of kiss
rosario's like no but I happen to know
that she would do it I've seen her say
impressed like I would love to play us
okay
I mean she's busy she's already got like
nine franchises but it's always Saldana
of course of course we also be anyone
who could make a more work that well
yeah and you know who else would be
great just like a Hedwig I think who
plays much a face
Colleen wing yes on iron fist Oh
actresses name in space and the
character's name but yes I think she'd
be amazing okay so that was the big news
man they're gonna finish Clone Wars and
stuff other big news is I don't know if
you've seen any of the imagery from day
one of comic-con preview night and on
day one which is today Thursday when
we're recording this show of course the
big trailer preview everyone's waiting
for is Aquaman James Bond's Aquaman film
and we've seen some stills and we've
seen some imagery from the movie and
stuff but thanks to Comic Con and the
trailers about to drop and I'm sure
we're gonna see some of this in that
trailer but we definitely saw it
reflected in the toys there on the floor
and the giant Lego that they made I mean
this is [ __ ] sounds so stupid that I
didn't think they'd do it but they're
giving Aquaman the orange shirt in that
movie man like they show images of him
and it's not like an orange t-shirt but
it's it's like armored and it looks like
a superhero costume but it is that like
orange whatever you would call it
[ __ ] tone man it was so it made me so
happy today
like honestly that's only and that's not
only the small attention to detail but
paid in this movie based on what I've
seen the Black Manta costume they fully
revealed looks exactly like the [ __ ]
comic book character looks exactly like
the superfriends [ __ ] villain and
[ __ ] he didn't shy away from going like
oh this helmets ridiculous let's not do
it he literally did that helmet and
there's a life-sized version of it on
the con floor and it does look
ridiculous like
I mean God it's ridiculously awesome
like and it's gonna play in that movie
in a big bad way that's the thing
Aquaman is soup to nuts 100 percent
dumbest [ __ ] so if you were gonna make
an Aquaman movie yeah just be dumb as
[ __ ] just do it all they show giant crab
people like people with crab claws that
stand all tall
I was like I'm gonna get so [ __ ] high
and watch this movie this is phenomenal
it is gonna be your yellow submarine it
really is all of it looks fantastic well
I think den of geek did a issue hand out
or something like that I know him as a
website but I think they did a San Diego
handout or something but there was
artwork for for Aquaman that showed
looks at characters that I haven't seen
portrayed in any other places and [ __ ]
including Orem with helmet on and stuff
ocean master this [ __ ] looks like the
truest comic book movie ever made like
it really hones close to the Aquaman
universe I know and the look of the
Aquaman universe I know we've seen Mira
she looked fantastic in Justice League
and you know maybe it was easy to look
fantastic it Justice League but like she
did she looks very on point for the
character and stuff but it looks like
James Wan was like ya know we'll totally
do Aquaman justice orange suit dig in
yeah he went for it I can't [ __ ] wait
I was excited to see the movie I was
always in the bag for it but this jacked
me up in a way where I was just like I
will [ __ ] put up I might just go
watch the trail or try to get in the
Hall H like a Normie tomorrow do you
know what I spent like probably more
time than I should have watching the
last couple of days tell me the Bohemian
Rhapsody trailer [ __ ] great isn't it
holy [ __ ] what our kids good actor is
great on funny like not in any way Hugh
close to the [ __ ] we're supposed to talk
about
aside from Flash Gordon and they better
spend like 10 minutes talking my flat at
least doing the Flash Gordon score but I
am obsessed with this [ __ ] movie and
I don't even know why
other than like I've been a queen fan
since forever and I know enough of the
story to know like spoilers he dies yeah
Freddie Mercury's gonna hit the iceberg
at the end of this boobie unless he
doesn't because the because he stays on
he's like live and then yeah because all
he does the score for Highlander and
thinks he's immortal and he's actually
end up being immortal you mean when he
was like who wants to live but that's
not even the only badass queen movie
song that they did of course Highlander
was awesome but they remember they did
Iron Eagle as well yeah well I mean that
was the one vision yeah that was a track
they already had that they use for Iron
Eagle is that right and it great if it
was an original song look at the Queen
fan I am I the closet Queen fan came out
I am a queen Queen like you wouldn't
believe
what about what was the other one up
born to be Kings we're the princes of
the unit you don't know the [ __ ]
words man
there's no queen van but here's the
thing here's like the thing to know
about Queen before going in and spoil
some [ __ ] is that you know Freddy again
spoilers had AIDS and died of
complications from said disease the last
live show they ever did was Live Aid
yeah and so and and the machinations
behind the scenes will look like Freddy
who had played stadiums his entire life
knew all right we're gonna play they
picked the time slot
they'd like to who was there and the
police were there and a bunch of [ __ ]
bands that we're gonna play this time
slot we're the only ones who've ever
played a [ __ ] Stadium and that was
their last show they ever played live
and if this movie doesn't end with Live
Aid I will eat my [ __ ] shoe because
it is the most dramatic wonderful moment
because they [ __ ] killed it everybody
written off queen-like Freddy's kind of
sick and he's not feeling strong and he
we're not sure he's gonna be able to get
out there on stage and for six songs
they tore it [ __ ] up and just to see
rami malek in that like the white tank
top with the [ __ ] studded bracelets
phenomenal and the mustache like the
mustache plays yeah absolutely
yeah it totally worked and I spent like
half an hour one day just watching it
over and over and over and over again
like how many kind of Leo's do we need
they've done two trailers now both
trailers are fantastic and totally
watchable over and over and over again
and Bryan Singer directed this movie
kinda mostly well kinda he's not the
director of record on the credits easy
not no no can you dude yeah is the guy
who was in what's-his-name LA he was in
Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels he's
an actor he comes the Matthew Vaughn
world if I remember correctly somebody
pull your phone up and you feel free to
yell if you have the information Dexter
Fletcher Thank You Dexter Fletcher is an
actor and he's directed as well but he
came in after Bryan Singer like flamed
out spectacularly or escaped I forget
what it was like he left the country or
something like that he took all so I
think that Dexter Fletcher was the one
that finished through the movie and I
don't know how much he did but
apparently Bryan Singer and mr. robot
Malick rami malek
like hated each other what it heads he
apparently didn't I've read an article I
think it was olive reporter movies where
they talked about like there can only be
one temperamental Queen in this band
I really have yeah I don't I I can't
wait to see it it absolutely looks
phenomenal my brother was a huge Queen
fan is a huge Queen fan but when I was a
kid that was like one of the first
albums I remember being played over and
over in the house like you know your
music usually is influenced by music
that you hear and before there was an
Internet and Spotify and all that [ __ ]
for there was digital music of any kind
it was my brothers records that
influenced the music that I would go on
to like in here Queen he was an early
adopter of Queen later on turns out he
was gay all makes sense now
but he informed my tastes and a lot of
things man so I is might be a movie I go
see with my brother he'll leave me I'm
all try and it'll be like [ __ ] you oh
I'm seeing her with my husband
so can I cut my yeah I might be a third
wheel on that date it does look
absolutely phenomenal I'm bored yeah I'm
ready to do that one I'm trying to think
what else came out of Comic Con today
anything that I knew specifically no I
think those are the two big stories who
did I interview today the black and the
predator good the predator is still okay
Brown is dreamy in real life he wasn't
there so I had the [ __ ] I but you know
is dreamy and very funny in real life is
Keegan
really Michael key yeah he was it was
very it was nice to meet him I've never
crossed paths with him but he was funny
you know he's known to be funny and I've
seen him be funny you know for years and
stuff
I've also I've seen him be funny not
just on Comedy Central but with the
[ __ ] President of the United States
remember when he was through through the
anger translator and stuff so to me he's
funny that's like one of the funniest
things ever seen in my life so he was on
the boat and I said something and he
literally like legit laughed and I was
like I made a funny person laugh like it
trust real [ __ ] it made me put a real
like air and my feet and then I was in
like way to go Kevin James and I was
like [ __ ]
I know exactly how that feels how do you
know I've made funny people laugh
occasionally yeah it happens yeah you
know sometimes on this very pop can I
when I was at The Hollywood Reporter
doing some story I think it was at the
end of the year thing and it was like
you know the the groundbreakers or the
the icons whatever every magazine
doesn't [ __ ] end of the year wrap-up
and so I pitched you know key and Peele
because at the time their show was like
in the third season it was killing it
and so we did a big photo shoot with it
with the two of them and I went to the
set of the shoot because that's what you
[ __ ] do with you can do and and I
remember we had this table of props like
just [ __ ] like Acme level props like
[ __ ] crazy straight-up Warner
Brothers animation props like giant
grenades and hammers and like a torpedo
and whatever and I remember that that
key and peele Jordan and Keegan
literally sat there for like 15 minutes
examining the tray of props like super
[ __ ] serious like we could uh we
could do something with this right
yeah what if what if what if I threw
this at you and you didn't catch it like
the weird serious business of comedy
analyzing and strategizing like you know
what be really funny I mean we're not
gonna be funny but it'll be funny if we
do this alright this is how you make
comedy it's really [ __ ] boring yeah
what if what if what if I put the
grenade in my mouth and you hit it with
the mallet
that'll be great sure guys I guess make
it funny then it was amazing when they
did I had never seen like I'm sure it's
like magicians talking about other
magicians tricks like that was great the
way you made that chicken come out of
your ass how did you do that
well I put a chicken in my ass and I
pretended not to notice and then the
chicken comes out of my ass and people
clap that's how we do this can I can
will you take me to one of your magic
show
[Laughter]
because the way you discussed the
chicken from the a thing you're like oh
it's so commonplace I've never seen that
mark I mean there's the castle behind
the Magic Castle with a weird [ __ ]
Castle were you playing tonight castle
behind the Magic Castle but like oh I'm
sorry I guess you're gonna be dealing
with the chicken out the ass aren't you
it's just a [ __ ] that's all we do you do
you want these flowers that's worthy of
a key and peele sketch right there I'm
working on it I like it all right man so
we're done talking about the news that
means we turn the show over to the other
part man generally well I don't know
well I'm trying to think man like
normally we go into the QA but you still
can well we can but I'm not sure if he's
here or not cuz I think you're here from
umberto are you here maybe not did
anybody see him Berto Ramos I mean is he
here told say like yeah I know him he's
great that doesn't help
no no he's not here I thought he was
supposed to meet up here all right talk
to him no he's a lovely man amazing
artists and stuff a little bit hopefully
we'll get him on a fat man at the yeah
please do at the cantina normally we do
this show at the scum and villainy
Cantina in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard JC's place and when we do it
our good friend Deacon is in the
audience and our good friend Deacon
works at the 4dx
joint man 40x if you've never seen a
movie in 4dx it's in a way another way
to consume media it's another way to
watch movie if you've never seen it do
yourself a favor
try it out man it's the it's the
experience the wear or whatever is
happening on screen starts happening in
the theater so if it's snowing in the
movie it starts snowing in the theater I
was really blazed and I want to see
Civil War
and opening shop in the movie it's on a
snowy terrain and all of a sudden it's
[ __ ] snowing on me I'm like this
shit's amazing so if somebody likes goes
on a motorcycle or car you smell burnt
rubber like it's real cool if you're
watching your chair moves the entire
time even during the credits if you're
watching Star Wars your chair goes back
so you can read the [ __ ] crawl and
[ __ ] it's a wonderful experience and
stuff 4dx theater there's one in Los
Angeles at LA Live I think they're I
don't know if there's one in Diego but
there's one on the way here yeah there's
there's one in let's say Pico Rivera and
Vista California and if you're in town
and you're like you're are living in
[ __ ] California they got him in
Chicago they got him in New York as well
they're starting to be everywhere so
Deakin gives us tickets that we like to
give out during the Q name as if people
ask cool enough questions basically we
got five sets of tickets to people to
five sets of two tickets yes so you get
to go with somebody as opposed to just
going by yourself like one please and
have people be like what happened so
what you do yeah why why don't you have
friends for this what we like to do is
we open this up to the audience let you
guys ask questions and stuff the only
thing that we ask is that the questions
have to be something we can both answer
so please don't ask something like
what's J up to mark doesn't know yeah I
can make some [ __ ] up but it won't be
true and I could give you a quick answer
he's in that room so
we like questions that start discussions
man let us go deep diving on on stuff
that we love and whatnot or talk about
writing being creative and stuff but
it's all up to you guys now I don't know
if we could turn up the lights in here a
little bit just to see folks but if not
we're just gonna have to do this kind of
[ __ ] oh yeah totally fantastic we're
gonna make this easy we'll start because
we're right here in the front so we can
get a mic in there and we'll try to work
back and ask for you to project when
it's time but we're gonna begin with you
young soldier has an amazing [ __ ] fat
man shirt you got on if it says I got oh
my god there is a party phone [ __ ]
hey well done man Rorschach give it up
for a man our sound guy how are you
what's your name
Matt everyone give it up for Matt Matt
man on Batman you have the floor ask
whatever you want don't get greedy yeah
what the [ __ ] Matt just give me an
engine [ __ ] I let you go for some titty
you go over third base as well what the
[ __ ]
keep it above the waist no God you get
two so you want a 40-minute answer it's
a lot of [ __ ] words now you're trying
to win all the tickets yeah
alright well let's try it we'll do the
first one first the first question is if
you could if you could recast any movie
with Muppets it keep one human character
who do you keep oh my god
someone said Ocean's eleven but Brad
Pitt's the only human and the rest are
puppets it's a good choice good choice
alright so let's see who you start you
ever start only because I've answered
this question already so [ __ ] cheatin
how the [ __ ] did you answer this
question already that's like the most
original question I heard but go ahead
uh Boogie Nights but what it is the dick
of Muppet as well fifteen inches of felt
baby what you keep Burt Reynolds
[Applause]
okay I got one big dick
that's pretty awesome I go Empire
Strikes Back
but Yoda is the human alright so that
was the first question in the second
question him them with the mic again one
more time or shark so we can go if you
could if you could recast the Avengers
first Avengers and we just have to do
the major the main line up there
including or not including Loki Agent
Coulson or no Agent Coulson
god damn son here we go all right let's
start will do character by character
okay eighties Thor go [ __ ] I got kind of
Brian Bosworth nice nice I go Alexandre
guten off from die hard
and money pit and ballet in general but
he would be low you ready at the hair
and she already had a funny accent so
it's all looking good
next up Captain America Captain America
1980s we're in the 80s what year
specifically doesn't matter matter
can we go late 80s Tom Cruise Oh Jesse
coming off of Rain Man I'm gonna do that
no I'm saving Tom Cruise okay
Chuck Tom Cruise's Ironman clearly Tom
Cruise but okay Captain America in the
1915 80s Chuck Norris and Delta forces
Chuck Norris as Captain America fair
enough okay so Ironman for you is Tom
Cruise is Tom Cruise Ironman for me in
the 80s Ironman in the 80s Oh William
Hurt from body heat and [ __ ] the
accidental tourist I mean sure I guess
he's more of a Reed Richards type but
I'm gonna stand by my stick with that
see you shows up at your movie
okay but but to be fair my guy did wind
up in an Avengers he really did yeah
John say it's not Avengers but in the
Marvel you and I Tom Cruise was almost
Tony Stark was he yeah
there was a time they were developing it
at Paramount and Tom Cruise is paramount
Golden Boy was almost Tony Stark but he
was like no I think that version of it
went away and then it resuscitated and
then we get the we get the world we got
the RDJ of it all yeah okay Black Widow
Demi Moore Wow Wow you you've been
waiting to say that for 10 years
I just [ __ ] came right out of your
mouth it's had that [ __ ] you got tell me
that that was your hello I mean my name
is inigo montoya like you were your
whole life you were ready to answer to
me more 80s you took to me more who do I
take Black Widow eighties I want to say
Stevie Nicks but they won't let me do
that I know who you should take Marisa
Tomei what a great call man my rookie
would have been Natasha Kinski ooh
especially if you're doing like 1981
yeah whoo that's good I might steal that
missed out Natasha Kinski all right it's
all yours just because I love you
because if now I'll take it we share
things and did we leave any Avengers on
the hall cruise manner so who plays
Bruce Banner in the 80s Bruce Willis and
Bruce Willis as Bruce Banner
I took the part cuz my name's the same
you got a turn green [ __ ] that
not doing it today James Spader
oh my god ass who Bruce Banner as Bruce
Banner he's more of a low-key somebody
just yelled low-key he does feel more
like a low-key to me no especially
because he was playing low-key like he
played the [ __ ] dude and pretty and
pink all shitty leaning on cards he's
like I wouldn't [ __ ] her with a stolen
dick I know that wasn't a line but you
know what I'm saying that was shitty
attitude Hawkeye you didn't do the hope
I didn't do much better I thought I did
who's my Hulk for habló hold on hold on
hold on hold on let me think let me go
through the 80s in my head Oh Michael
Keaton and I get him before he's Batman
[Applause]
Jeff Goldblum is the hole Oh mr. Hogg oh
my god it's the one incarnation of the
Hulk where I'm like [ __ ] the Hulk bring
back Bruce Banner he's way more
interesting and way more [ __ ] up
alright so Loki Loki I liked James
Spader as Loki I might stand by that
what about you he's bad guy eighties bad
guy robert davi Alan Rickman
[Music]
you'd never get them are you actually
might've man like diehard was what
eighty nine ninety is Britt eighty-eight
and that was just break out yeah so yeah
you might you might again on you would
have had mean look we all love Tom's
low-key but holy [ __ ] he would have been
the truth that was a great question you
definitely win tickets given missus
[Applause]
alright who else we got thing they want
to know is right there or sure you're in
charge you get to pick the people it's
more democratic we will not beat up
afterwards take all the power too much
hey how are you what's your name
everyone give it up for Dylan are you
for like from Australia did you say
that's a long [ __ ] commute man thank
you and welcome welcome to America
welcome specifically to California first
ever been here oh well then you have to
try bisexual sex we're known for it here
in California that and avocados so yeah
[Music]
you can absolutely try but I don't work
with it no George Carlin was mine hands
down like I've been a lifelong George
Carlin fan and then when I got a chance
to cast him in something it was
absolutely magical like and he was a guy
that lived up to all your hopes and
dreams he was never on he was never
trying to make you laugh except when he
went onstage and stuff but offstage he
didn't feel the need so he could be
funny conversationally funny and stuff
but he wouldn't work you like like a
comedian worked you if you hang out with
Tracy Morgan for ten minutes you'll be
exhausted at the end of those ten
minutes like jay-z works constantly he's
constantly [ __ ] on so you go home
your face hurts from smiling all day
long George wasn't like that he could
just sit there and have a conversation
with him and stuff like that he didn't
feel the need to try to make you laugh
unless he was doing his [ __ ] thing
but he loved acting and it was so cute
and so adorable to see him be so [ __ ]
serious about it somebody who is such a
goddamn natural genius at the thing that
they didn't choose to do but backed into
doing George Carlin one of the greatest
[ __ ] thinkers this nation's ever
[ __ ] produce one of the greatest
comedians will ever know
but he didn't want that he wasn't
seeking that that's something he wound
up doing what he really wanted to do was
act so whenever we put him in one of
those movies even those dopey ask Kevin
Smith movies he was delighted because
that was his lifelong dream he'd always
wanted to be Danny Kaye growing up that
was his role model he wanted to be a
funny song and dance man in movies so
when he showed up on our sets he was
serious as a [ __ ] heart attack man so
most people were like George Carlin's
here this is gonna be hysterical
and then George would get to set and
he'd be like Kevin I have a question for
you as the director and writer of this
material and I'd be like recognized and
he and he'd be like Jay and Silent Bob
strike back he's like okay I'm reading
this scene here man and in this scene
you know I'm talking about the rules of
the road and I'm telling these [ __ ]
about the rules of the road am i serious
about this the unwritten book of the
road or am I just [ __ ] with these
[ __ ] and I was like I don't know
when I wrote it I always thought the
character is kind of serious about he
goes that's what I thought I thought
that too he's like I'm glad to know
we're on the same page about this and I
was just like I'll be honest with you
George like you really don't have to
give it too much thought
you're just the truck of the guy that
blows truckers so
and he goes no no no I have to give it
all the serious thought he's gone that's
what an actor's job as an actress an
actor's job is to bring truth and
honesty to the moment so that it works
and he's gone so I need to know these
things these are important because I
have to go out there while the cameras
running and do this so he's like I got
to make sure the moment is too honest
and I was like George bring as much
truth to it as you like so he working
with him for me was a dream come true
because he was a man I respected
obviously beyond most others in this
life and most others that I'd met even
before I met him I respected him more
than most people but working with him
was absolutely delightful because you
got to see a side of him that he'd
really reserved the rest of the world
didn't see you know George was I
wouldn't call him cynical bunny
stretching the imagination but he was
definitely a guy who had a sense of
humor and a very specific point of view
and whatnot and it didn't leave much
room for hope joy laughter and love and
[ __ ] like that like and he had those in
his life I'm not saying he didn't but
like you know one day I'm dogma George
pulled me aside like while we were
sitting not not pulled me aside like
come here we were sitting in the chairs
and [ __ ] waiting between takes and he
goes Kevin can I ask you something as
the writer and director of this material
that was the way he started most
conversations and I was like absolutely
recognized and he goes you know a lot of
this you know I grew up Catholic as
Catholic as you grow up apparently
that's why I like the script so much and
stuff he's going in fact you know how
you told me back in the day when I first
met him and she sat down and talking
about the script I said what did you
think of the script and he goes I really
like the script kind of feels like I'm a
little responsible for it and he goes
and in some pages I would like
co-writing credit
so he took it because he really related
to the materials so we're sitting there
on set and he goes like I get it I went
to Catholic school like you I was
Catholic like you and stuff like that
but he's going Kevin you're 27 years old
do you really still believe this stuff
and you know I had to look my master in
the face and tell him like yeah there's
a part I still pray before I go to sleep
at night and he goes oh he goes why
didn't I ask you this before I took the
job but it was awesome to kind of sit
next to him and watch him work because
he was like a kid again like suddenly
you know the hardened George Carlin that
we saw on stage went away and the kid
who just wanted to be an actor when he
grew up came out on set but he was so
[ __ ] serious about I've told the
story a zillion times I'll tell it one
more time and then cede the floor to
Marcus I'm sure he has his answer ready
now we were rehearsing on Jersey girl a
movie that nobody saw and so when we
were rehearsing a Jersey girl was me Ben
Affleck and George Carlin in the morning
sitting down and like when you rehearse
it's like any other [ __ ] job you get
there and you don't go to it right away
everyone's [ __ ] around doing [ __ ]
George was folding out his script
opening it and folding it so that he can
read his pages of the script closing and
stuff Affleck was making coffee and then
he came over and joined us and George I
swear to you this is exactly how the
conversation started you're in a laughs
what is true he goes Kevin I have a
question for you is the writer and
director of this material that was this
very funny way of starting conversation
so I said recognize and he goes he goes
you know in the script
my character is always given greenie a
lot of [ __ ] greenie was the character
that Stephen root played and he was
always giving him [ __ ] like what are you
stupid and [ __ ] so he goes I'm always
giving greenie [ __ ] he's going but
there's no clear reason why I would ever
do that I'm always just stepping on his
dick for no good reason he's gone so
what I did was I was thinking about last
night I wrote myself a backstory he's
like I wrote six pages about how greenie
gets on my [ __ ] nerves and [ __ ]
what he did and that [ __ ] that pissed me
off and still pisses me off and why I'm
always giving him [ __ ] and he's like I
just want you to know I wrote it
and I memorized it I put it into my head
it exists there I've since thrown out
the pages I'm never gonna refer to them
while we shoot the scene but I want you
to know that when I'm yelling at greenie
that's what I'm gonna be drawing for to
make the moment more real and I turned
to Affleck and I was like why can't you
be this [ __ ] God what's your answer
my friend jesus [ __ ] christ okay okay
so there was a time I wanted to write
comic books yes and and I and I managed
to convince a small publisher out of San
Francisco get him Larry Young who ran a
itai tea planet Laura - uh sure knots in
trouble absolutely I I kind of like
shanghaied him into like dude I've got
this idea for a book and it'll be great
and he said let's do it you just need to
write it and well you won't get paid and
that's fine but I wanted a comic book so
I was willing to do the work and we were
some kind of conversation about
something or other and he was like you
know would really like you Jim Lee
Jim Jim Lee I think would you guys both
love action movies you're both kind of
living in or he was with the school in
Jersey you're living in Jersey I hadn't
met you at the time so that Jersey
didn't come into play but he's like I'm
not so narcissistic where I'm like where
am I in the story mark and so he's like
I think he really liked Jim I'm like
that's great I think I would too
cuz he's [ __ ] awesome but I have no
way to get well here's this email
address you should email him and I tell
you want to do comics and you do one for
me that didn't work at all and so he
gives me the email address and so I get
work up some moxie I have a couple of
shots of whiskey and I'm like [ __ ] an
email Jim Lee and say how to pitch you a
comic book so I write the email nothing
because why would [ __ ] Jim Lee answer
my email all right that makes all the
sense in the world
and so I would do this thing where I
emailed him every week for 50 weeks and
these emails would get like [ __ ]
weird just like
I'll let him out of the box if he went
to the email signed Cletus and he would
never answer these emails because he's a
smart [ __ ] man who's running a comic
book company he was running wild store
him back in the back of the time right
and and so finally I realized cuz I was
also a magazine editor at that time and
I would get pitches from freelancers
through the email and it was always like
the dudes who were [ __ ] were the
ones I would never email back like
listen I get that you have a story you
want to tell you're not telling it to me
right now cuz you're an [ __ ] so I
emailed Jim like at the 52 week mark
almost a full calendar year of being an
[ __ ] I said Jim I'm sorry I've been
an [ __ ] because I get these emails
and I don't I don't answer to them
because I don't like to do business with
[ __ ] so this will be the last email
I ever send you I have a story that I
kind of want to tell I think you might
dig it if you want to listen that's
great if not I'm sorry and so he emails
me back and says I'm gonna be in New
York in three weeks let's have coffee
and so I meet him for coffee and I pitch
him this story and I see him like he's
super [ __ ] civil generally is that
nicest guy at least very polite he's
super sweet to burn let's go and so like
we're in this coffee shop in Manhattan
and I'm pitching him this idea and I see
him start to sketch and he's sketching
the characters that I'm pitching him in
this idea and by the end of my like 10
minutes spiel about what this thing is
is like I will do the book I was like
what does that mean it's like I'm Jim
Lee it means we're gonna do the [ __ ]
book and I said oh and that was a book
called the highwayman which I pitched
him in a coffee shop in Manhattan that
he greenlit that then came out that now
DC is making into a movie because I
pestered this [ __ ] for a year
and then realized that I was being the
[ __ ] and that book was very much the
first thing the real entryway into comic
books because of Jim Lee that is [ __ ]
up and that's an awesome story
Wow so yes in in a very very real way
that do change my life yeah you know
like if I didn't write comic books and
every would have got an agent if I
didn't get an agent I wouldn't be
working in TV and I all I blame it all
on Jim Lee Wow so whenever you see me
that's [ __ ] sweet man that's really
cool but wait I go back to they are
making they're making a movie yeah we've
talked about yeah we do mention the
podcast yeah it's I mean it's a book
that we wrote for DC my writing partner
Adam Freeman and I and DC owns it they
owned it outright because as lovely a
man as Jim Lee was it's like you ain't
got no credits [ __ ] we are gonna
take all the rights of this [ __ ] but
we'll pay you to write it but if we make
a movie we're keeping everything and
that's what that and that's what
happened and I was but you'll see your
name on the screen and then I will it
will be based on a comic book created by
so-and-so I will get a little tiny chunk
of change they will fly me to the set to
shoot some EPK footage to be like tell
us about how you cream the character I'm
like it was awesome and then they'll
give me one ticket to the premiere not
to just one my fat ass down on the
[ __ ] green carpet or whatever and
we're like I did all this and they will
say we don't care if you get interviewed
on the red carpet when you walk away the
Billick writers never have wives they
always come alone
yes nobody wants to [ __ ] that guy that
was a great question yielded great
answers give the man some tickets that
you've come to America and you won
something take us there Rorschach where
we're going next you pick them give it
up for a pal
done Raphael for you thank you mm oh
[ __ ] damn son because of your knee where
else is your knee wire to and is the
knee bone connected to the heart phone
[Music]
congrats man
thank you my takeaway from that is don't
go jogging but I'm super happy you're
healthy but that's number one thank you
for that that's very very [ __ ] sweet
of you to say but it's so weird nobody
has ever been like do it like Kevin
Smith
that feels [ __ ] weird dear so thank
you yes do it like Kevin James makes a
lot more sense mess up my wife says to
me all the time do it like Kevin James
I'm like alright [ __ ] you like I'm the
king of queens [ __ ] that is true
it's funny funny and a little shitty
somewhere Adam Sandler's like why we're
just friends yes Hotel Transylvania made
like a hundred million dollars leave me
alone he's crying his eyes out on his
money
I'm sure anyway back to you yeah you've
dug the new Black Lightning show it
doesn't seem to fit how how would you
guys bring black lightnings universe
into into reverse excellent question
how would I bring them in I mean they're
not obviously set in any of the Berlanti
universes that we know right like thus
far they haven't established anything
and they've said so far that they're
keeping them separate that might be to
the benefit of black lightning because
at the end of the day you know on the
other shows like the flash is a show
about a boy who solves all these
problems by running really [ __ ] fast
and you know you can't outrun racism so
like I don't know
are you sure this is it all right - boy
Jesse Owens is the flash run Jesse maybe
they won't catch you run Jesse run so
maybe it's to their benefit that they
kind of keep it separate and not be like
you know hey [ __ ] this year's
crossover Black Lightning joins the fun
because it allows them to kind of do
superhero stories with more
sophisticated or or kind of socially
conscious material in a different way
but obviously it's easy to bring them in
the same way they brought Supergirl into
like flash they just have to be like oh
[ __ ] she's from another earth and
apparently black lightnings from our
earth so we'll see if we'll see if they
ever want to play in that world I think
that I wrote a book called static shock
for DC for all of thank you thank you I
wrote it for all of two issues before I
got canceled because comics and the the
story that I wanted to write like I
wrote two issues the next one that I was
gonna write was gonna be about a
blackout in New York and how static
shock had to static needed to use his
power to keep New York alive for just
long enough to fix the blackout and so
the and the tension of the story was
there's awful [ __ ] happening in
Manhattan and I meet I'm the only one
who can keep the lights on and I can't
stop the crime that's happening because
there's hospitals and schools and
support staff and everybody needs me to
be at the center of the city and keeping
it alive and so I think there's a world
in which unity is a blackout across the
arrowverse of course the Berlanti verse
to introduce Black Lightning and like
how are we going to open the [ __ ]
dimensional portal how are we going to
do whatever how are we going to keep the
people we need alive alive without
electricity Black Lightning is a
solution to that problem and also static
would be an amazing introduction to to
the to the Berlanti verse especially the
black lightning verse the what's it like
to be the old hero with
- fingers who have to deal with like the
young kid who does it a completely
different way but also has the same sort
of power the same skill set but yeah
like I just and growing up in New York
in the 70s and remembering what that
blackout felt like you know remembering
were you there yeah I lived I lived in
the Bronx
during the 76 blackout and just like
there's like it's I think there's some
sort of symmetric like for meals is what
it takes before humanity devolves into
barbarism like if you miss for meals
people go [ __ ] nuts look as the
Weight Watchers ambassador I think I
should be the responsible one and step
up and say that's not necessarily true
I've missed four meals and I'm still
civil the people I haven't I mean
anybody that is from your perspective
that's true but that that idea that
feeling of you know and I get it was
[ __ ] August in Manhattan and there's
no power and so the heat is driving
people crazy the lack of services are
driving people crazy like there was
looting there was and I will also say
below story because the blackout in New
York ties in to why there is disco did
you know this know NY actually hip-hop
comes to happen because turntables were
very [ __ ] expensive okay right and
disco was the music that birthed out of
the gay rights movement because it was
illegal for men to spend time with other
men and women who spent time with other
women in New York in the country for a
long time until they dropped that law in
like 74 and so men were like listen if I
can dance with a dude I want that dance
to last all [ __ ] weekend long and so
clubs in New York would do this thing
with us say well what if we put a fader
between these two turntables and the
sames the song can keep going I can
switch we can record and record and the
beat never stops and these dudes are
just dancing all night long but
turntables were expensive like nobody
really could get their hands on [ __ ]
turntables until there's a blackout in
New York and everybody [ __ ] ludes and
then everybody can have a [ __ ]
turntable and so like the vid guys in
the Bronx were like well we don't need
to blow this [ __ ] disco and the best
the disco are the look the drum breaks
in the middle of the song and we have
the faders and we have the [ __ ]
turntables and guys want to dance over
the break because that's what they like
breakdancing happens literally because
you could get the 15-second drum break
and extend it for two or three minutes
and that's breakdancing the guys like
well this is where it danced over the
break maybe somebody can like sing a
song over the [ __ ] break I can't sing
but I can rap rap happens all because
ultimately there's a blackout in New
York and suddenly people steal the [ __ ]
that they need to make the art that we
all love that's [ __ ] amazing give it
up for a history of brief histories so I
would like a music I want to black out
in the arrowverse so we can have [ __ ]
hip-hop there's your answer man
phenomenal response what a great
question you definitely win tickets give
it up for him ladies and gentlemen well
done rough out take is there Rorschach
where do we go next
hey Ben everyone give it up for Ben got
an unfair good answer but unfair one
because I've got an inside track on it
buckaroo banzai which a couple years ago
we sold and then I walked away from it
but something tells me it's maybe coming
back
I'll let you know more that when I can
but that's they were creating franchise
aroma crock the writer and WD Richter
had a whole universe of stories so much
so at the end of that movie there's the
slug that says buckaroo banzai will
return and buckaroo banzai verse the
world crime league there's a promise
sequel and they talked to big created a
world and set it up where like
adventures have been going on for a long
time so much so that there were even
comic books within the movie based on
the buckaroo banzai character so it's a
movie that lent itself to like instant
universe I universalization or whatever
the [ __ ] like you can turn it on and
suddenly you could keep going with it
unfortunately people in see the movie
when it came out in theaters and stuff
and and it went away and then became a
cult hit on video so I think they've
tried to do it a few times over the
years including what's-his-name
Shawshank Redemption
you know Frank bender by Frank Darabont
did a version that he pitched I think to
NBC like for network and stuff but
they've they've not been able to find a
way to do it again yet I think that
lends itself to it's a franchise that
that's just waiting to happen
I think it might happen - what about you
I think Jonny Quest I think I think
there's there's time there's room like
we're in a place where we could actually
do like a live-action Jonny Quest and
and and make it for real and I don't
think I'd do him as a boy I think you do
him a little bit older because the thing
the thing that I would do if it was me
if Warner Brothers says hey buddy do you
want to have this thing and all the
money I would make I would make it this
story about you know Johnny coming out
of college he's lived his entire life
like in the showers father doesn't want
to be an adventurer at all and
encounters races daughter who comes to
him and says help my father's been
kidnapped and I don't know what to do
about it can you help me and Johnny's
like I don't want to [ __ ] be that guy
I want to be a doctor I want to help
people
it's like well
help my dad and it turns out that his
dad has been kidnapped by [ __ ] who was
like [ __ ] you for dragging me across the
world when I was a kid I had a family
why am I in your [ __ ] planing like
fighting elephants and weird alligators
and aliens and mold man in this [ __ ]
like I had a life you turned me into
this thing that I didn't never wanted to
be and so your big bad guy is the is the
Indian dude and he knows everything
knows everything about everything about
like everything about that world every
[ __ ] secret password every every dirty
[ __ ] adventure they didn't never told
you about [ __ ] [ __ ] know he knows
where all the bodies are buried
yes and he knows who the bodies are
buried in so uh so yeah the math checks
out yeah so yeah that's that's the one I
would do I think there's there's totally
world for like you know the young
Indiana Jones of today about the sins of
the past revisiting itself on the
present so yeah I like it man that's a
great question you win the tickets give
it up for my that was one two three so
far
three so far I can't do mom one so far
got two more so we got two more to go
fine to somebody else for sure
Lizzie everyone give it up for Lizzie
Lizzie allusive is it is it is it like
pull the football away Lucy or is it
like nice as in Lizzie Borden took an ax
gave her mother keep an eye on this one
what can we do you for Lizzie okay you
didn't get a lot of support on that one
man there wasn't a lot of [ __ ] yeah
she's right there was a lot of quiet
like I'm judging her I'm familiar with
Killer Croc go on
Oh sweetness I really do like reading
about DC villains and yeah okay I think
well they're already making 96 different
Joker movies so obviously not the Joker
but in terms of Batman villains one that
has look I would look no further than
Paul Dinis heart of ice mr. freeze from
the Batman animated series they took one
of the simplest dopiest characters in
Batman's Canon is a man with a freeze
gun and turned him into the one of the
most tragic Shakespearean level villains
of all in all of comics I would I would
do mr. freeze you get a lot of powerful
material there and and also you know the
freeze gun visually is a cool thing to
see I would imagine on screen like we've
seen it and already done a few different
times just not the Arnold version please
but yeah I think I'd go mr. freeze you I
used to see you yes
who would you cast in my mr. Frese movie
would be a good mr. freeze like and
don't say alan rickman you'll make me
cry i wanna [ __ ] but he would have been
perforating that is good not bad yeah I
I think I would want a rash uncle movie
I think I because I love that's a like
the big global threat bad guy who's so
much [ __ ] smarter than your hero and
he's got a point right like I want a
villain who's got a point he's kind of
like Thanos like vanos is like look I
just want to kill half the universe
because survival of the other half and
that was also it was also kind of Ra's
al Ghul's philosophy as well if you know
mankind has done horrible things to the
planet so we should have just raised
them like lolis weird we're the worst
yeah just abundantly clear so maybe fix
that and also Lex Luthor like I love
that that Lex Lex is the Superman of his
story Lex is the one who actually like
listen I'm the best possible hope for
Humanity I've done all the work I
[ __ ] pulled myself up from my
bootstraps I've got a billion dollars I
I can make everything better for
Humanity if you would only trust me and
then [ __ ] Superman shows up and [ __ ]
all that up you know it's like he goes
from being Metropolis his favorite sons
in Metropolis his second favorite son
and unravels and becomes Lex Luthor
because of it yeah so like the tragedy
of Lex Luthor which again is all through
his eyes because he's our point of view
character is actually kind of
heartbreaking and I did all the things
right I have a vision that you won't let
me execute I could answer all of your
prayers prayers arse card
it was almost problems of prayers and I
got caught in the middle because
[Music]
say bars purse but yes one of those two
like I'm all about those big beds I like
it man good a good question give tickets
to that what
who would I cast who you cast is Ra's al
Ghul as Ra's al Ghul Naveen Andrews oh
yeah yeah he's good yeah
Wow that's good and Lex Luthor not Jesse
Eisenberg who I got god yes wrote in
Vince Vaughn but not the comedy Vince
Vaughn the Vince Vaughn who was in
psycho the crazy [ __ ] serial yeah I
think he could pull off lex luthor cuz
he's got like a lot of charm but there's
something dangerous going on behind
those eyes ah Tom Cruise you know what
that's a really good pull right yeah
because Lex Luthor is desperate to be
loved and Tom Cruise is Tom Cruise likes
being loved as well so just I just need
to write like 19 running scenes into it
just so he can [ __ ] do that thing oh
did you ever hear the secret of the Tom
Cruise run know the secret of the Tom
Cruise run which if you're a fan he does
in every movie and it's amazing because
it's the special effect of the Tom
Cruise movie his secret is you don't run
with your fists closed because the
camera can't catch it so [ __ ] like
robots Scissorhands Ronny so that every
[ __ ] hand movement the camera catches
and like ramrod straight
I forget which Mission Possible it was I
think it was JJ's Mission Impossible
third one where he does this ridiculous
long run where they must have set up a
cable cam and [ __ ] and he ran for no
[ __ ] if you watch that movie feels
like almost half a mile and you're
watching it you're going this is pretty
good cinema
look at him go just keep looking going
like there's gonna be a seam it's not
gonna be him sooner or later so now the
whole time it's literally just Tom
Cruise you know what you know like why
did I pay for this because you know that
at the end of that take the like you
know what we didn't get it Tom we got to
go back to one and he [ __ ] walks all
the way back the mile and a half he ran
is like I'm ready to go JJ just tell me
when Scientology gives me strength he's
like I could do it a couple different
ways I could run if you want I could
slide out my underwear for a half I got
range that was a great question you get
tickets pass on those he gets one we got
one more do we have one more yeah we do
unfortunately we have to we have to
start wrapping up there is a show after
this show and the guy who's in that show
is a real [ __ ] [ __ ] so we don't
finish up he gets all sorts of tight but
take us there or take us to our fifth
and final question of the evening hey I
[Music]
see you hang okay I'll allow it continue
we've been out of the we we've been a
few places we've done a little traveling
I know we've done Detroit you know we've
done Indianapolis Indianapolis
we've been out on the road but I mean
it's really it's not up to us it's not
like I sitting there going like we'll
wait until they really want it like if
somebody asks us generally we tend to go
in Colorado this [ __ ] will show
up tomorrow to Colorado for that rocky
mountain high but yeah but I would
imagine that the show has grown in leaps
and bounds over the course since we've
been doing it really at the scum and
villainy Cantina suddenly the show found
its exact niche like in the beginning it
was just me interviewing people who
worked on Batman that was lovely and
stuff but at a certain point you just
kind of run out of that that road and
then we started doing together and that
was fun and stuff and then the section
of the show that was the utility belt
got bigger and bigger as we talked about
news that the show was less and less
about Batman than anything else and
stuff so when we did the home versions
or the YouTube versions that was just us
no audience that was fun but it wasn't
it never felt like this felt the version
that we do now that we do every week at
the scum and villainy cantina which is
pretty much what we're doing here
tonight feels like the right way to do
the show the only problem with the show
now though is the title doesn't really
work that well there's no Batman yes
there's no fat man yes I mean I'm trying
to keep it I'm trying to hold it down I
know it's getting harder and I was like
for the sake of the podcast don't lose
weight I've I've always felt that Warner
Brothers was very sweet and very kind
about letting us go first long as we've
gone because at the end of the day
they've never called up to be like hey
[ __ ]
you don't own Batman like stop saying
and [ __ ] they Leslie after kick Justice
League in the balls as hard as we did
honestly I kept expecting a cease and
desist go on like you know used to be
cute and I are an [ __ ] stop
but but no but sooner or later they are
so it's a conversation that comes up
periodically and it'll come up more and
more frequently which is like what would
we we spent so long building something
and calling it something and identifying
as something but at the end of the day
the show is really you and I sit around
talking about [ __ ]
so that title doesn't necessarily it's
not the only title the show could ever
have in Stowe we skiddy vegan on negan
that's adorable but if that was the case
every episode I'd be like this [ __ ]
negan is ruining the show you can't eat
meat stop eating the ribs no veggie
grill those nachos are very good so yes
hopefully we'll be able to take the show
out into the world more this year
because the show has kind of grown is
what I was getting at this incarnation
of the show the one that we do in front
of the audience and it leads audience
questions sometimes we have guests and
stuff like that
sometimes the guests arrive a little
late I understand Humberto is here but
arrived you know a little bit ago the
that that version of the show has caught
on in a nice way it gets bless you we
get a lot of press like you know [ __ ]
when Markus and McFeely were on the show
it's like they weren't on the show it's
like hey Markus and McFeely said this
[ __ ] about DC look at they were also on
a podcast
yeah that's Cameron Smith had something
to do with there was a lot of like well
first many articles is identified where
that information come there were some
that were just like they told Kevin
Smith and it was like now they told
Kevin Smith and Mark Barnard but they
conveniently leave them out sometimes so
the show has kind of grown to what it is
now and I think it's an easier for lack
of a better description cell to the
outside world like you know we do just
fine in our world
stuff but it's tough to convince
somebody else like no seriously they
just sit there and talk to each other
about comics and people show up it's
weird so so now that they can watch a
whole episode on YouTube and whose
episodes go like sometimes two two and a
half [ __ ] hours long and [ __ ] it's
easier to kind of send to a club and be
like hey do you want this because now we
get answers back like [ __ ] no but we'll
get out there Colorado we have standards
yeah but you better be better so we'll
get out there and in the world then as
soon as people pull us out there
generally where you find us is where
we've gone traditionally is of course
comic book shows comic book conventions
makes a lot of sense but you know at the
end of the day we could totally do
comedy clubs as well and not because
we're like so super [ __ ] funny but I
used to be really like weirded out about
doing comedy clubs I'd always come in
with my head hung low and [ __ ] because I
comedy clubs are places I Revere genius
people get up on stage and generate and
[ __ ] make you think and feel and
laugh which is so [ __ ] important and
I never felt like one of those cats I
never earned that I didn't get up and
build the slow material and [ __ ] like
that so I wound up at comedy clubs
because of the movies because I would go
out in Q&A afterwards and I say try to
say some funny [ __ ] and so sooner or
later they were like go play clubs and
every time I come in I'd be like I feel
weird doing this man because I didn't
earn this and [ __ ] like I'm not a real
comic I'm a [ __ ] tourist and every
person that owned the club would always
take variations the same thing though
like there's just an empty room man and
you bring an audience and that audience
likes you and that's all any comic does
as well so yeah you come with an
audience and maybe they don't always
come to the comedy club he's like that's
actually good for us that brings new
people into the [ __ ] doors he's going
but don't make two [ __ ] cents about
it he's going you are a comic you fill
that [ __ ] room so we could take the
show to comedy clubs as well and just be
like 60% less laughs than you're used to
but the thousand percent more comic
books and hopefully take it out on the
road that was a great question but that
does not win [ __ ] tickets
I bought we have ten sets so today that
does win [ __ ] tickets pass it back
some tickets to Spenny man well done sir
so one more we should do one more than
do one more so that provides something
that's a little less self-serve horshack
where you gonna take us there or show
you a baby test us in the back first off
what's your [ __ ] name I'm so excited
you went right for my badge
stop it like [ __ ] kiss me first [ __ ]
what's your name give it up for Adam
everybody all right Adam what do you
want to know I know it sucks and it
ruins the movie for you forever cuz
you're like they should have done marks
okay sorry
we feel bad about your first [ __ ]
world problem there man well it tends to
work best for movies that haven't
happened yet lately that's what's been
happening like the other day on the show
two weeks ago I guess it was we went
deep on the Creed trailer and like the
whole audience and us built a fantastic
Creed movie that they're probably not
making at all
but boy we're all amped for it well like
that's gonna be amazing and we're all
gonna be really [ __ ] disappointed when
we see the movie so I like doing that
but what it's all usually usually best
for the movie you haven't seen Aquaman
would be a prime way to do that okay
Aquaman knowing what we know and I don't
really know a lot although I've spoken
to some journalists who like look dude
just go to one of their junkets they'll
tell you everything and I was like
really they're like yeah they're not
[ __ ] hiding anything now they're like
no no this is what happens in Aquaman
please come yeah I mean I'm fairly
certain some of it takes place
underwater besides that I don't have any
real intelligence on Aquaman all right
so let's try to build an Aquaman movie
you'd like to see using I you know I'll
keep you know what's being used in this
movie take what you've seen mm-hmm and
build a movie out of that I mean I'm uh
I'm gonna I'm gonna pull a little bit of
inspiration from the Joker okay which is
if you're good at something never do it
for free [ __ ] know where they give
you an Aquaman movie I hope there's some
like punching of [ __ ] underwater
[ __ ] I'll tell you what there better
be or else I want my [ __ ] money back
he needs to be like I also want this
Aukerman to write a [ __ ] jet ski
because if you remember the Superfriends
that [ __ ] never swam anywhere it
was we gotta sell this jet ski toy so
let's have the king of the [ __ ] ocean
ride a [ __ ] jet ski yeah so
yeah I want some ski-doo action in this
or I'm done they they showed I guess it
was Entertainment Weekly or something or
revealed a sea dragon that he rides upon
and then they showed it side by side
legging all the old cartoons they always
showed him riding a giant seahorse and
they were like how pathetic except when
I was a kid I was like that ain't
pathetic that's [ __ ] metal
but could you imagine there was a
seahorse that [ __ ] big most people
like seahorses are cute that [ __ ]
would eat you man and like but Aquaman
had tamed he's like I'm riding this
[ __ ] beast and [ __ ] so they've made a
sea dragon they call it that looks
essentially like that image of him
riding on top of sea dragon at one point
we're gonna get him riding on top of the
sea dragon hopefully not sexually but
it's underwater so it's all different
I know if he says drew Karis then I will
lose my [ __ ] [ __ ] could you imagine
and she took care of me and then the
water like the flame don't come out
because they're underwater but it's
boiling water and it melts [ __ ]
faces let's see this is a better version
what we just did we did the thing you
asked for I I look forward to that movie
in a big bad [ __ ] way man not the
least of which for the reasons that like
everything looks the way it should look
and stuff like that this is the first
entree into the sea for either of these
comic book big two franchises for the
Marvel or the DC or anybody we haven't
really spent much time under the sea
except like what [ __ ] do you think
anything in the DC Universe under the
sea I'm no I'm just talking about in
movies other than like Little Mermaid
and [ __ ] how much how much time have we
ever spent under the sea
finding dory I mean but cartoons don't
count well I mean you know abyss that's
what I was thinking but that goes way
far back that means that you go in the
cage cage goes in the water splashes
sharks in the water oz is more
superficial they lived up here except
the camera did this I mean here's what I
want if Jason Statham does not kick a
shark in the face in the Meg yeah I'm
gonna be [ __ ] furious yeah fast and
furious I don't want to see an Aquaman
yeah there there I hope there will be a
scene it will not happen because
whatever where Aquaman like his every
movie needs your hero to be at its
lowest point the all is lost moment
where everything I wanted is gone
everything I hope for won't happen my
dreams are shattered and somebody's
drinking those shattered dreams like
[ __ ] cocoa somewhere I want him to be
in a desert I literally want Aquaman to
be like you were nowhere near the sea
you have none of your [ __ ] power
you have to now be a man you have to
prove yourself worthy of the throne and
how better to do that than the Strand
him nowhere near the water nobody near
his beloved [ __ ] fish and he's got to
fight his way through I don't know
better ones sure to get back to the
ocean that's not bad but if that
happened in the movie I'd be like I paid
$20 to see Aquaman [ __ ] this sand you
know bug me I want to see him in the sea
save that for like the sequel and [ __ ]
first movie it better be all [ __ ]
under the sea they better be singing the
whole [ __ ] time
well here's well and then I want Paul
Atreides to show up and be like I can
help you get to the sea brother oh right
yeah giant worm [ __ ] Aquaman
crossover do that [ __ ] and he's like I
could control your worms this is what I
want to see in an Aquaman movie other
than him [ __ ] using that I want to
see him weaponize a shark or a team of
school of sharks sorry
so like the [ __ ] bad guy it's like
worm the ocean master they fight but
warms got a lot of armor so I'm hoping
to Christ at one point he's like and he
sends [ __ ] 96 sharks to judge ter
[ __ ] arm part and [ __ ] which looks
like it could happen but the armor saves
his ass and [ __ ] or even better they
just [ __ ] and they do shred a
[ __ ] like 25 sharks just shred
so many people like truly you are the
king of the Seas I I would like them to
explain when Mira has heels on an
underwater costume why you need heels
for your swimming [ __ ] everywhere if
she don't make much better she wearing
heels in case she has to run from a
t-rex come on Marc use your head
I think anything that's oh my god that's
good enough though question man that
definitely gets tickets give him some
[ __ ] tickets well done
I wish we keep going especially because
I'm Bertos here but unfortunately we got
a show after this that we got clean up
for and get out of here and stuff like
that so I promise humberto you get a
prime slot at the scum and villainy
Cantina and we dedicate the whole show
to you ma'am not this week we're not
doing a show this week not for a couple
of weeks well really ya know what next
week there's no one next week because
I'm gonna be the dick and be like I
there's a Castle Rock premiere that I
need to go to
oh is that what you're doing that is
what I'm doing well that's worth
canceling the show like I'm sorry
everybody I gotta go see a TV show
um that's sweet though where are they
doing the premiere at the bad robot
offices oh I've been there man they got
the rooftop screens they really do it is
like imagine like Willy Wonka also
having all the [ __ ] money who decides
he wants an office and builds it fills
it with toys and [ __ ] that is the bad
robot office like it is literally like
childhood playground with adult money
just run wild here's here's just a very
is a charming detail about the bad robot
offices when you come in to the waiting
room just same as you come into
anybody's office or a doctor's office of
[ __ ] waiting room usually has couched
some chairs and some magazines some
newspapers the it bad robot there's like
a you know coffee table that's lower
right in front of the couches that
you're sitting on a chair and it's full
of paper and pencils and crayons and
[ __ ] like that and they just write
create so as you sit there you like hey
just wanted work and the other thing
they do is they have like post cards
that are blank and they're like fill
this out and send somebody in the
service a greeting in the Armed Forces
like it's just creative and beautiful
and wonderful like Mark said like
there's [ __ ] toys galore it's like a
toy Museum and they change and add
things all the time like it's one of
those offices where I walk in I go like
if I was talented this is what I do to
like you know buy at this kind of talent
that had this kind of money and that
kind of like when you walk into those
offices you realize whenever he walks
into somebody else's office they're like
make it rain
Pagar and the easy gets those jobs he's
got an office to show for I'm like you
drive by it's on Olympic I think and the
signage outside is not bad robot inside
its National typewriter company yeah
it's what's on the walls yeah like you
know I get it
that's fine I'll allow it but you watch
your step JJ so that's gonna be the
premieres on Tuesday is gonna be [ __ ]
awesome to watch with everybody and then
you're out of the box on the 31st so
we're back in August
alright so it'll be two weeks before we
come back back home yeah if you've never
been to fat man I'm Batman down in Los
Angeles come on and join us at the scum
and villainy Cantina it's a fun time
down there and stuff and and there's
also like a chance that we bring guests
like we Humberto will be coming with us
and a couple weeks hopefully we had we
had chayo Coker the Luke 8 showrunner
last week share was wonderful it was
amazing we have Markus and McFeely we've
had we've had a bunch of people and it's
been great yeah hopefully we'll add more
and stuff but at the end of the day like
we don't like to be dependent on guests
like it's nice if they're free and
people could come but we just like it
where we get to like talk to each other
and stuff like that's a dream job or you
get to sit around and talk about things
that you're excited about like most of
my life I have to talk about the things
I generate right I'm salesman
essentially and I'm always like hey I'm
working on this please buy this please
buy this this show is literally just
getting the kickback and be like ah this
is all the [ __ ] I love there's this [ __ ]
that's gonna make me happy this is the
[ __ ] that when I wake up at 3 in the
morning I'm like what is America I
remember this and I'm like [ __ ]
everything else and I go back to sleep
and [ __ ] like that this is the [ __ ] that
like when I was laying on a [ __ ]
table and they were telling me like you
only have a 20% chance to live from this
heart attack I was like [ __ ] you I'm
gonna live to see Avengers 4
[ __ ] like so
I can't speak for Martin but I certainly
love doing the show and I'm pretty sure
Marc agrees and stuff and that has
everything to do with the audience half
of the show we were talking about last
time we walked off the stage at the
stage after we walked out of the bar the
scum and villainy cantina I was like
it's so [ __ ] crazy like we only
really have to come up with like half a
show and then the audience generates the
other half with the questions and stuff
so as we are lazy yeah it's just like it
would be like that would start seeming
like a job it's like you had to do
everything but it's nice knowing like we
could come with stuff to talk about but
the audience will always give us the
rest of the show to talk about so thank
you for that it makes our lives easier
and it makes it fun for me cuz we don't
know where the [ __ ] thing's gonna go
like at the end of the day somebody can
get up and ask a question be like why
are you alive [ __ ] and shoot us both
and then you guys to be like those
greatest episode of fat man I've had man
I've ever seen do it again and the
headlines will be Kevin Smith dies
unnamed black ladies and gentlemen if
you had a good time this evening give it
up for the guy without whom there is no
fat man I'm Batman the man sitting next
to me mr. mark but not and
and that is Batman on Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I am look for
naxuan the next time same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast comma or
youtube.com slash happy honey comic-con
everybody enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you